la magie de noël malgré le coc vite
c'est aussi les illuminations où l'avez
peut-être remarqué à tour elles ont
débuté il ya une heure et ça fait tout
de suite son petit effet lucas chopin et
paul boyer ont recueilli vos réactions
j'adore les décorations
je les trouve très belle l hôtel de
ville est très beau avec des lumières
violette comme ça je trouve que au
niveau de la décoration la ville de
tours et est plutôt bien loti j'aime
beaucoup parce que ça permet d'illuminer
la ville notamment la place jean jaurès
etc ouais je trouve que c'est plutôt pas
mal ça redonne de la vie avec tout ce
qui s'est passé avec le confinement et
où je pense que les gens ils ont un peu
besoin de gaieté comme d'habitude un de
toutes les façons chaque année on a des
décorations qui sont superbes
donc voilà quoi oui ça fait plaisir
forcément ça donne un petit côté festif
qui manquait forcément l'esprit de noël
c'est comme si la voir régner partout